a movie that most los fagans know by
heart celebrating its 25th anniversary
casino gives us all a look back into our
city's gritty and glamorous history
and tonight some of the film's key
players look back on their experience
sasha loftis joining us live from a part
of the channel 8 property
that acted as a set for some pretty
iconic scenes in the film
yes brian well if you've seen casino you
probably recognize this room
it is here on the channel 8 property and
it's just one of many
small ordinary parts of our city that
help bring this film to life
today we got the chance to get a better
look back at those
it's been 25 years since casino
first hit the silver screen and its
reverence still holds true here
it was a time of sort of you know
glamour
and glitz and and promise and
opportunity
and also a lot of heartache and violence
you know
but that is sort of the big the las
vegas that people
really identify with to celebrate the
classics anniversary
screenwriter nick pillagi and former las
vegas mayor and attorney oscar goodman
led a special event on thursday sharing
the parts
they played in this well-known
masterpiece
didn't just live through the era he also
portrayed himself
in some pretty iconic scenes i've been a
lawyer here for 35 years and
the mayor here for 12 years and i go
into an airport and they say oh there's
a guy from casino
the creators also reminisced on the ways
news stations like ours
helped writers bring local history to
life
it's taken literally from you know the
news footage that was taken by channel 8
at the time
so you know that was very important to
creating an authenticity
as we all look back on these pivotal
moments
these men will always remember
pretty cool right well there is an
exhibit at the mob museum completely
dedicated
to the movie casino it has different
props signed scripts and some photos
of those who were in the movie including
former mayor oscar goodman
if you'd like to check it out but for
now reporting live in las vegas sasha
loftis 8 news now